il y a beaucoup de gens qui nous
rejoignent à 21h2 et là on va revenir
sur cette affaire qui nous inquiète
énormément c'est l'affaire Lina cette
jeune femme qui a disparu depuis le 23
septembre dernier qui est introuvable et
il y a eu énormément de pistes
énormément de choses dites est-ce qu'on
peut faire un point et il y a de
nouvelles infos Michel Marie sur cette
disparition juste avant j'aimerais qu'on
viienne bien sûr qu'on r viienne sur
toutes les pistes qui ont été explorées
et que vous nous donniez les nouvelles
nouvelles infos parce que il y a encore
des nouvelles infos dans cette enquête
depuis le départ les depuis le 23 3 le
23 septembre cette jeune fille qui qui
avait 15 ans s'est littéralement
volatilisée bon peut-être pas rentrer
dans tous les détails on connaît
l'histoire un petit
peu après avoir soupçonné le petit
copain Tao on s'est apçu que il n'avait
à priori rien à voir dans cette
histoire les gendarmes sont partis un
peu tout à s d'abord ils ont ils ont
ratisser les les lieux sonder les étends
fait tout un tas de vérification évoquer
la fugue éventuellement une F amoureuse
et depuis le départ on a un témoin qui
me semble primordial c'est un certain
Robert on en avait parlé sur ce plateau
il y a un petit moment c'est ce monsieur
qui avait des lunettes un peu teintées
voilà il avait vu passer une mais Robert
Robert voit éta grise et entre le bleu
et le gris bon en tout cas Robert depuis
le départ a
vu Robert depuis le départ a vu Lina
dans une Clio peut-être bleue peut-être
grise mais à priori grise et ce qui est
très important c'est qu'elle n'avait pas
l'air d'être enlevée d'être en état de
panique elle lui a fait un petit coucou
donc
elle c'est le dernier témoin qui qui l'a
vu et puis ça corrobore finalement tout
un tas de d'événements qui vont arriver
après parce que
rappelez-vous toutes les les clios bleu
ou grises qui ont été vérifié le
professeur de musique qui été placé
c'est en garde à vue qui a été
perquisitionné pendant 2 jours et cette
Clio grise elle est vraiment au centre
des des choses et là depuis quelques
jours on a l'impression que l'enquête a
progressé justement pour nos
téléspectateurs qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé depuis quelques jours alors depuis
quelques jours la gendarmerie a contacté
en fait c'est le le collège Frison Roche
qui est au centre de de de de l'enquête
tous les parents d'élèves ont été
contactés par la direction de l'école et
puis également par la gendarmerie ils
veulent savoir si leurs enfants
fréquentaient une aire de jeu qui est
située à
solxur c'est un endroit où les jeunes se
retrouent fume des cigarettes boivent
des petites canettes et on a vu à
plusieurs reprises un individu dont on a
le signalement et on a même mieux qu'un
signalement puisqu'on a sa photo un
individu d'une vingtaine
d'années qui abordait les les les jeunes
les ados en leur proposant en leur
demandant s'ils avaient une cigarette
donc donc c'est son mode opératoire pour
rentrer en contact est-ce que tu as une
clope ça c'est un élément qui vient
d'arriver ça c'est un élément qu'on
vient d'avoir nous après je sais pas
depuis quand les gendarmes long en tout
cas à mon avis pas très longtemps et cet
individu donc qui a une vingtaine
d'année il a entre 20 et 30 ans il est
blanc il portait un haut de survêtement
et un t-shirt noir et il a une Clio
grise ah ouais et ouais il a une Clio
grise et il a été pris en photo par un
témoin il a été pris en photo par un
témoin à l'arrache la photo a été prise
comme ça en à
paparazzi et les gendarmes ont cette
photo ah c'est fort et donc ils ont
montré cette photo à un certain nombre
de de d'enfants d'adolescents du fameux
collège Frison Roche là je ne sais pas
ce que ça a donné en tout cas il cherche
à identifier cet individu mais
finalement tout s'imbrique bien tout ce
tout ce corbord face à ça ça corrobore
avec ce qu'a vu Robert c'est-à-dire la
et j'ajoute j'ajoute que à chaque fois
on a demandé aux parents d'élèves de
communiquer les identifiants snapchat
des enfants des ados parce que les
gendarmes sont persuadés qu'il y avait
un lien avec entre cet individu qui
rentrait en contact avec les les
adolescentes donc ils font des rech B
c'est ce qui expliquerait qu'elle était
paisiblement installée dans la voiture
et qu'elle faisait coucou à Robert
d'accord ça veut dire qu'elle le
connaissaz bah voilà d'accord c'est fou
et donc là Guan Clio euh il est donc il
a il abordé tous les tous les ados alors
ça on n pas j'ai pas d'information mais
en tout cas il semble qu'il est abordé
plusieurs ados et aussi détail important
que j'allais oublié de vous dire 2 jours
avant la disparition de Lina il y a une
jeune fille une copine de Lina
d'ailleurs qui a été abordé par un
individu assez jeune qui était dans une
cliot grise quand même donc ça commence
à faire beaucoup les cliot grises
surtout dans un tout petit village comme
ça quoi et et et ce garçon l' pu
l'identifier ou pas du tout ben non il
est pas identifié enfin à ma
connaissance il est pas identifié photo
ne sera pas diffusée par la police pour
essayer de le retrouver alors je pense
qu'il en est question enfin je pense
qu'ils y ont réfléchi il y a des
avantages des inconvénients ça c'est le
juge qui décide de de diffuser une photo
en plus le risque c'est si vraiment il a
rien à voir avec avec toute cette
affaire on le désigne comme comme un
monstre avant même il y a une autre info
on ne savait pas c'est quoi cette
histoire de plainre pour viol déposé par
Lina au printemps 2022 alors c'est le 27
juin hein 27 juin 2022 à peu près un peu
plus d'un an avant un an avant oui un an
et et 2 mois 2 mois et demi ou ouis euh
Lina euh va à la gendarmerie déposer
plainte pour viol contre deux individus
majeurs et à l'époque elle avait 13 ans
et 8 mois je crois d'accord euh elle
dépose plainte donc pour viol elle dit
que les fesses sont passées au domicile
d'un des deux qu'elle connaissait un
vague copain priori elle elle elle était
souvent avec des des gens plus
agâgéquelle et donc là elle avait été
invitée à une soirée et puis les choses
se sont se sont mal passées à priori au
cours de la soirée et elle dit qu'elle a
été violée par deux de ces de ces de ces
garçons donc elle dépose une plainte les
deux les deux hommes désignés sont
interpellé placé en garde à vue entendu
par les enquêteurs ils vont reconnaître
non pas le viol mais en tout cas avoir
une relation consentie avec Lina et très
curieusement je dis bien très rieusement
je pèe mes mots ils n'ont pas été
inquiétés c'est ça l'ffaire a été
classée son ce qui est hallucinant parce
que elle est mineure de moins de 15 ans
et le simple fait d'avoir une relation
sexuelle avec une mineure de moins de 15
ans avec ou sans son consentement avec
son consentement c'est mieux entre
guillemets sans son consentement de
toute façon de façon systématiquement on
doit être poursuivi pour atteintre
sexuel incroyable cette info c'est
incroyable je je ne comprends pas j'ai
pas j'ai pas l'explication on on a
entendu ces deux jeunes hommes ou pas
comment ils ont été entendus ces de
alors ils ont été entendus à l'époque de
de la plainte ils ont été à priori
réentendus dans dans le cadre de la
disparition de Lina et la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on va enfin se repencher sur ce
dossier de de de plainte sur cette
affaire de viol malheureusement
peut-être un peu tard puisque de toute
façon lina a disparu mais en tout cas
euh le parquet concerné qui est le
parquet de Saverne je crois euh a décidé
de rouvrir enfin de se repencher sur le
de relire le dossier et de voir s'il y a
pas eu un loupé je pense qu' Michel pour
nos téléspectateurs qui nous rejointent
j'aimerais revenir de petites secondes
sur le suspect recherché parce que c'est
vrai que ça fait beaucoup hein est-ce
que c'est un suspect qui était déjà dans
les dans dans dans le quartier dans le
village ou pas est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui qui qu'on connaissait pas
qui et qui qui est parti après a priori
c'est plutôt ce ce cas de figure il a
été vu repéré puisque quelqu'un l'a
trouvé tellement suspect qu'il l'a pris
en photo ouais et c'est cette fameuse
photo que les gendarmes n'habitait pas
dans le voilà c'est pas quel a priori en
tout cas ils l'ont pas trouvé donc c'est
on est quand même dans les petits
villages où tout se sait où tout le
monde se connaît on n'est pas à Paris ou
à Marseille donc a priori ça peut être
un travailleur saisonnier qui vient
quelques temps et puis qui qui tourne un
peu en rond avec sa voiture et puis qui
qui repart ailleurs mais je pense je
jeis optimiste je pense qu'on va le
retrouver il a il a abordé au moins deux
adolescentes qui ont été identifiées au
fameux collège Frison Roche et là ils
sont en train de voir donc là on est en
septembre ils sont en train de voir
auprès d'un autre ét
ement s'il n'aurait pas entre guillemets
Séville en octobre pour aborder d'autres
adolescentes sur un autre établissement
c'està-dire savoir s'il y avait une
sorte de prédation dans la région voilà
ils sont en train de ou ou oui voilà ils
sont en train de chercher sur septembre
octobre alors toujours autour des
collèges et des aires de jeu d' voilà où
il semblait Svir il garit sa Clio à côté
ce qui a permis à des jeunes filles de
dire il était en Clio mais à ma
connaissance ils n'ont pas encore la
plaque diat culation ce qui permet pas
de remonter à cet homme suspecté c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont non'ont pas diffusé
sa photo encore mais son portrait robot
si je puis dire 20 ans blanc assez grand
je crois signalement pardon barbe et
moustache voilà ils avancent sur la
description de de ce suspect potentiel
il disait quoi aux personnes qui
l'abordait je ne sais pas visiblement
bah il y avait un côté il avait l'air
suspect il disait quoi histoire de
cigarette et puis il était quand même
beaucoup plus âgé que les les gamines
qu'il abordait c'est
gamin des femmes il a C des jeunes
filles ou des adolescentes ou d'accord
et il leur demander des cigarettes c'est
tout ou demand que tu as une clope enfin
c'est histoire de c'est un moyen
d'entrer le fait qu'il était pris en
photo le fait que les gens en a parlé
c'est que voilà parce que il est très
intéressant
comportement c'est ça il avait il avait
absolument et et le le pseudo sur
snapchat ah oui comme le lien est quand
même établi enfin c'est l'info est
sortie en même temps ça peut vouloir
dire peut-être qu'il établissait un
contact avant sur les réseaux sociaux
it une sorte de
TR et si c'est le cas c'est comme ça
qu'on le retrouvera absolument c'est ça
ils sont en train là d'explorer ils ont
demandé les pseudos snapchat aux parents
de toutes les adolescentes du collège
les identifiants voilà et ils vont
remonter en essayant de décrypter qui
aurait pu entrer avec en contact avec
ses adolescents sur snapchatê pour les
caméras dans les villes vous moi je suis
pas pour caméas partout partout partout
en France voilà voilà cette histoire
cette histoire vous prouve que vous êtes
encore à côté de la plaque d'habitude
j'ai pas l'habitude de vous engueuler à
21h13 aujourd'hui je vais le faire parce
que ça prouve exactement que vous êtes à
côté de la plaque il eu des
caméras c'était terminé on l'avait en de
secondes Gilles Verdez une fois de plus
à côté de la plaque excuse-moi j'ai pas
l'habitude de t'engueuler à 21h13 mais
je pas pour les caméras non mais
vraiment mais comment on peut dire une
énorme connerie pareil c'est pas
possible excuse-moi tu m'énerves jusqu'à
21h14 ça n'est jamais arrivé tu vois
bien que tu vois bien comment tu vois
bien que là typiquement le cas là c'est
typiquement un cas où on aurait
l'histoire aurait été résolue en en en
une heure voilà mais à cause de de de
Guignol comme toi voilà et ben on va je
te le dis bah si parce que c'est voilà
il faut des caméras de surant partout
tes copains de la LFI je pense qu'ils
sont contre voilà c'est pas mes copains
là on on est sur cette cet ex 21h14
excuse-moi toi excuse-moi mon Michel
excuse-moi toi euh on on est sur cet
exemple là mais il y en a combien comme
ça des centaines peut-être même des
milliers pour toi Michel moi je suis
pour moi je suis élu dans ma dans ma
commune et je suis en train de m'occuper
je suis en train de m'occuper justement
de de l'installation de la
vidéourveillance dans un dans un petit
village on en veut partout de la vidéo
surveillance merci merci Michel merci à
T d'avoir été avec nous tout de suite AC
la vérité qui compte
merci